how can you tell if the man is wearing
the beast or the Beast is wearing the
man now old man has no more tales and
maester Luwin will never scoff again
that's fine I don't like scary stories
anymore because I'm in one the realm do
you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight and game theory video in today's
video I want to discuss a theory I came
up with shortly after season seven had
ended as of right now I don't think
anyone else has made a video about this
possibility before the first time I
talked about this my channel was about
half the size that it is today so now
that we're almost 400,000 strong and
only a few months away from the final
season I want to know what people think
about this idea today I do admit that
this is one of my 10 foil theories
however I think the evidence does show
that something like this is possible no
matter how unlikely it may be the main
reason why I felt like discussing this
again is because I have noticed a large
portion of my subscribers believe the
night King will not die I know this not
only because of the type of comments
that I see but I also had people vote on
what they thought would happen to the
night king so if you are one of those
people you may find this video to be
interesting so with that being said
let's begin let's start off the video by
going over some of the things we do know
about the 19 as we all know the White
Walkers were introduced at the beginning
of the pilot episode but we weren't
introduced to the night King until
season 4 episode 4 this was during the
time that Chrysler was leaving his sons
out in the woods as a sacrifice to the
gods in this episode we finally learned
exactly what that meant Crestor was
giving his sons to the White Walkers who
had didn't take them all the way to the
lands of always winter where the night
king was waiting when the white Walker
arrived with the baby in hand he placed
him on an altar made out of ice this was
when the leader of the White Walkers
finally reveal himself
along with one of his powers now that
was obviously very impressive at the
time but what the night king was able to
do after this had many fans left in
shock the next time we saw the night
king was during an episode known as
hardhome this was when Johnson Oh went
to hardhome to gather up as many
wildlings as he could but the night king
was not about to allow that to happen as
the wildlings were beginning to leave
with Jon they came under attack by
thousands of whites as they were leaving
Hart home the night king revealed
himself once again but this time he
showed us just how powerful he truly is
during a very tense tear down the night
king lifted his arms and when he did
this all of the Fallen wildling started
to reanimate after a few moments all of
the dead wildlings were standing back up
but this time all of their eyes had
turned like blue stars just like the
night Kings and the White Walkers the
night King was able to reanimate
thousands of wildlings at the same time
unlike anything we have ever seen before
we still don't know exactly how the
night king is able to do this but since
he was created by the children of the
forest who get their powers through the
old gods and/or the weirwood trees I
imagine it's very similar to what brain
stark is able to do with the dire wolves
or Hodor as I have said before bran in
the night King are getting their powers
from the exact same source in my opinion
this information started to get revealed
when a brain stark was training at the
three-eyed Ravens cave when brain was
there we eventually see him go into the
weirwood net on his own and when he does
this he finds himself standing in front
of a large group of whites when brain
was approaching the Horde of whites it
became clear that they were completely
motionless almost as if they were asleep
that was until Bryan got to the back of
their formation where the night King and
the white walkers were waiting for him I
tend to believe that this was one of the
many setups by the night king since bran
was inside of the weirwood net he did
have a false sense of security which is
exactly what the night king wanted him
to believe however when the night king
turned his head to look a brand all of
the whites turned around simultaneously
all of them were now staring directly at
bran in the dream state inside of the
weirwood net was now turning into a
nightmare the night king showed us once
again just how powerful he is after all
this was brain Starks vision yet the
night King was the one who had the most
control over what
as we all know the night king was able
to reach out and grab brain by the arm
which eventually led to the night king
getting inside of the three-eyed Ravens
cave however this might not have been
the biggest revelation of that episode
later we find out exactly who created
the night king in the first place during
another flashback we could see that a
man was tied up to the weirwood tree
with a gag in his mouth then we see lief
begin to approach that man while she has
a dragonglass dagger in her hand when
she pushes the dagger into his chest his
eyes begin to turn icy blue the same
color blue as all of the White Walkers
and the whites there is a reason why all
of their eyes are the same color as we
all know the night Kings eyes are AC
blue and that color transfers whenever
he takes control of something this is to
show that the night king is the one who
is in control over that person or animal
we have seen this exact same thing when
brains dark as well whenever brain is
getting ready to do the same thing we
can see that his eyes turned white this
also happens to whatever animal or
person brain begins to enter this is the
show that brain stark is the one who
isn't controller for that animal or
person just like what the knight came
since the night king was created by the
children of the forest I think it's safe
to assume that he is getting his power
from the same source as them after all
they did create the night king as a
weapon to defend themselves
so it would make sense that he would
have some of the same abilities as them
and this is why bran and the night king
are able to do some of the same things
that's because bran is getting his power
from the old gods or the weirwood trees
as well not only can both of them enter
the weirwood net at the same time but
both of them are also able to control
other people or animals as we all know
the only problem for bran is he hasn't
learned how to harness these powers yet
the night king has had thousands of
years to practice whereas bran has only
had a few now there is one special
ability that both of these characters
should possess only we haven't seen them
do it yet because they haven't had to
you see when a person has the ability to
enter the mind of another person or
animal they can use this right before
they die therefore they continue to live
through that other animal or person's
body they do not have to stay trapped in
their own body as it dies we get many
examples of that happening in the books
but we have already seen this happen in
the TV show as well and as you all know
whenever the
introduce something in the show the
chances of them doing that again are
very high back in season three when John
Snow is traveling with torment in
Ygritte we meet a character that has
that ability this character goes by the
name of RL and he just so happens to
travel with an eagle as they are making
their way to Castle black they come upon
an old man who Jon Snow is ordered to
kill this is something that John needs
to do to show that he is one of them but
when John refuses to kill that old man a
fight breaks out during that fight John
is able to stick his sword right into
orals chest but right before he dies he
leaves his body then enters of the bird
once he's inside of the bird not only is
he able to continue to live but he's
also able to continue to attack John
Snow this is kind of fascinating so now
that we know if the character has this
ability then they don't necessarily have
to die for good once their original body
begins to die they can leave that body
and continue to live in something or
someone else now let's think about bran
stark in the night king they may be able
to take this even a step further because
we have seen them take control of a
person not just an animal
in the books there is a character who
goes by the name of Veera mere six skins
and he also has the same ability but he
is able to control six animals at the
same time now what's interesting about
this character is he actually tries to
do what I referred to earlier as he is
about to die he attempts to enter
another person's body that way his
conscious can continue to live this
happens somewhat shortly after Stannis
attacks a man's his army right on the
other side of the wall during this
attack ver Amir flees from the scene and
he ends up getting stabbed by some
little boy when he tries to take a cloak
off of his dead mother Vera mere knows
that this injury will kill him so he
begins to contemplate leaving his own
body to enter another instead of just
using the body of some animal he wanted
to take things a step further by using
the body of another person the only
problem is it doesn't quite work out
well for him this isn't something that
he has much experience with when he
tries to enter the body of a woman named
thistle she has a terrible reaction as
if a virus has just entered her body she
begins to scream and claw out her own
eyes
she even bites off her own tongue and
Vermeer can actually taste the blood
so he does leave her body and he enters
one of his wolves instead very mere six
skins wasn't able to pull this off
but perhaps another character could I
imagine that if another character were
able to do this it would have to be a
character that has a lot of experience
with being inside of another person's
body since brain and the knight King
both seemed to be the most powerful
characters who are tapping into the same
power source my money would be on one of
them we have seen the night King enter
the mind of other animals and even other
people but so far all of them have been
dead what I want to propose is what if
the night King tries to enter the mind
of a living person what if this is the
big twist at the end of the series what
if he does this to try to escape his own
death as we all know Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen or on a mission to
defeat the night King but what if he
leaves his body right before it gives
out now I know that we're not exactly
sure if the night King has that power or
not but we may have been given another
clue during season seven when we saw a
brain star go to spy on the night king
the night king almost immediately sense
to that brain was there the big-ass
flock of birds could have been a dead
giveaway but it could have also been
something else
we know that bran stark is a
skin-changer and as I have said I also
believe that the night King is a
skin-changer as well another interesting
thing about these characters with this
ability is they are able to sense
whenever another one is close by so even
if the night King did not spot those
birds in the sky he still could have had
this sense that brain was near since
they shared that same power when the
night king did look up at the birds they
almost exploded which did cause brand
tax at their bodies almost immediately
it seemed as if the night king had
forced him out of those birds his mental
abilities are still far superior to
brands and this is messing with his head
like I said earlier the night king has
had many many years to learn how to
harness all of these powers unlike brand
there was also one other thing that
makes me think that maybe the night king
cannot be killed Jon Snow said something
during season seven that may have been a
big clue for the end game when Jon and
company went out beyond the wall to
capture a white we learned that if you
kill a white Walker you can also kill
everything that white Walker reanimated
when Jon killed a white Walker we also
saw all of the whites that were with him
died at the exact same time
that led beric Dondarrion to suggesting
that if you kill the night king then you
should be able to kill everything he
reanimated which is essentially the
entire army of the Dead I thought this
was a reasonable solution after all we
did just see it work with one of the
white walkers but Jon Snow's response to
this was very interesting there's
another
kill him
he turned them all
you don't stop why did John Snow say you
don't understand does that mean this
plan will not work or does that mean the
night king cannot be killed there is a
theory that says brain stark is the
night king and many people believe this
will come true because bran will
eventually get trapped inside of the
night Kings body but I wanted to flip
that theory on its head during the final
battle against the night king right as
Jon Snow or whoever is about to deliver
that fatal blow what if the night king
leaves his own body by entering bran
starts we have already seen the night
king take control of brains vision and
we have already seen the night king
force brain out of those birds but what
if the night king takes over brains body
next let me know what you think about
this idea do you think it's possible or
is it batshit crazy leave your thoughts
or questions down below in the comment
section I want to thank you all for
watching another video I really
appreciate that and also want to thank
everyone on patreon who continues to
support the channel I hope you all have
a great day I will see you again very
soon bye
you
[Music]
you